uh I'll just elaborate on the
introduction a little bit and welcome
everyone thanks for joining uh I I work
at quanite labs and my co-presenter
today is Hae Hae could be here today
like unfortunately but that's all right
like I do want to shout him out because
he played very critical role in putting
the stock together uh especially like
the primary framework we look at today
uh was uh was all uh H so uh both of us
work at quanite UH ha works on a lot of
cond tooling I work on on cond store
which we'll also discuss towards the end
of the talk but I work on nibari and
Boke to other tools in the Val
ecosystem okay so let's I guess bring
some context what this talk is about and
then we'll slowly dive in so uh the
title suggests run time reproducibility
uh so we let's start with like what this
even means right and like what are we
talking about today
so um almost all the time we discuss
around time reprodu simp it arrows down
to these five words um it works on my
machine and it can be your application
your script your notebook however for
today because this is longtime
reproducibility we are not cons not
concerned with the uh library and
building packages as much as uh the
Final End user experience right and what
does Works mean an imperfect definition
is uh repeated installation uh and
execution steps provide a consistently
correct result a lot of words but we
have the rest of the talk to understand
that and finally your machine can be oh
my video is covering it but I'll just
read it out WG definition of Hardware OS
kernal libraries executable binaries a
lot of things uh form the machine part
here uh sometimes it's also not just
your system it can be slightly um it's
it's it's the space around it like your
that the current date can sometimes
affect uh affect your runtime
environment because it can serve as a
seed for something else right so that is
what we are covering and honestly like
packaging itself like python packaging
in general is a very deep broad Bast
rabbit hole and we are not going to
enter that rabbit hole we are just going
to like run around the rabbit Warren and
there's a lot we can do there honestly
and that's what we're going to cover
today right so in open science uh
there's uh this is a wonderful Matrix
created by the Turing Way community uh
they Define reproducibility
as actually I haveing right here uh they
Define reproducibility as when the same
analysis steps performed on the same
data set consist produce the same answer
so we have data and Analysis there is a
layer missing here right or you can also
consider that a part of analysis which
is sorry tooling um and the tooling part
is also critical in reproducibility and
that's the part we are going to focus on
now we've I guess um I think the context
is clear like what you're talking about
in terms of runtime reproducibility um
now the key takeaway in the St honestly
is this um to ensure runtime
reproducibility we need to be proactive
about it and how to do that is what
we're going to
cover reproducibility cannot be an
afterthought and needs to be modeled
early that's what we mean by being
proactive right and how do we do that we
can borrow certain uh a framework from
threat modeling and uh why do we do that
because St modeling also needs to be
super proactive right like um security
uh you can't think of security like when
when there's a security breach it's too
late so we need to be planning for that
very early on so the four steps in this
framework are defining your objectives
for reproducibility uh enumerating
components evaluating threats and
finally once you have once you know the
threats you apply reasonable measures to
overcome them going through these one by
one so what do you mean by defining
objectives here um the whole idea is to
think about this before the application
is complete so uh you're thinking about
like when you're working on something um
what is my definition of reproducibility
for this application let's just take
application as an example for today
right so it can be when you say for
example it it I wanted to work on my
machine but like what exactly do you
mean by that is it just your machine is
it your machine in two years is it all
the machines in your organization uh
should this be uh should this work in a
deployed setting uh does this need to
work on everybody's computer across
across the planet so uh defining what
reproducibility means for your
particular use case is step
one next is enumerate components so once
you have that definition you can now
start looking at your um software your
your work and um find pieces that you
need to to look at right and you can
categorize them as things that you own
right these are things you have control
over which usually includes your
software itself but also some data or
your server but there are some things
you will need to delegate out like all
the dependencies like you I think you
cannot realistically manage all the
dependencies that uh your application
needs right and at that level you need
to delegate that out to other
maintainers in the ecosystem uh
sometimes it's also your infrastructure
uh that we get out so next is just
looking at the pieces of your
work sorry three yes three is evaluating
the threat now that we know the pieces
um we can think about what happens if
this piece doesn't behave the way I
expected to um so an example here is uh
your we looked at server and data right
what happens if my like where I've
stored my data that goes down uh is that
a risk I'm willing to accept right like
what is the risk here even so
uh or your server goes down or like
there are some dependencies right so
maybe look at looking at um these are I
have like these 15 dependencies maybe
three of these are super critical um
what is the threat level or the risk
level if these three uh somehow break so
looking at and evaluating all the threat
aspects here and once you know the
threats you can apply certain
measures um so if you when when we
identified those three critical part
packages maybe you decide to render them
to minimize the risk if you think your
data is not stored as uh like if if one
place is not enough buildin redundancy
there so you can then apply certain
measures so with these four this is like
the framework that we can follow now
let's look at a concrete example of
python in
web that also really cool so that's kind
of why we chose this example uh but this
same framework applies across the board
for for notebooks and scripts and such
so this uh is just a basic example I'll
walk you through what we did right uh we
looking at um wakes and streamlet like
there was a blog post that we found
which was super interesting U building a
web app and actually taking a step back
what is streamlet and wges for folks who
are not familiar I don't want to just
throw J there so streamlet is a um is a
library that lets you build web
applications in Python right uh it's
really cool like lets you build a lot of
things for quickly and Wix is a high
performance data frame Library so you
can do things a little faster than I
think different libraries okay so these
are the apps you're putting them
together to create a cool Dev app now
the first thing we noticed was the block
was was very nice but the hosted app was
down because the website was down
because of some DNS serves of course
it's dnss um however the source was
available in the blog post so that's
awesome we went to GitHub and there were
requirements of txd file so now I know
that I can rebuild this on my machine
and then check it
out uh the requirements of TT file ran
pretty smoothly like there was one typo
uh but other than that we just assumed a
python version python version does not
specify so that's an assumption we made
and um then things kind of worked like
that's why there is a
there however what this doesn't
Encompass is there was a really really
large dependency tree behind the scenes
right so at best the txt was under
specified now what does this mean like
uh I'm not this is not like a particular
uh like taking a day at somebody that's
not the case here like this I have done
this before right there there are there
are applications I wrote three months
ago that don't run right now because I
didn't do certain things for
reproducibility so uh let's look at what
actually happened here the main thing is
a lot of things were delegated out what
were these things the app runs on stream
Cloud but the domain was
down uh uh the uh
hosting was being delegated it wasn't in
the own section second dependencies on
pii and being online which is honestly
which is a level of risk I think most
folks are okay with accepting right uh
python version wasn't specified so that
is delegating the version aspect to the
users like um but maybe that's you maybe
I end up using like I don't know Pon 3.6
will it still run I don't know um but we
obviously chose a recent one um make a
more recent version sorry and lastly
platform OS uh is obviously needs to be
inferred again being delegated to the
user which um I ran this on my like mac
machine and I just hope that it worked
but maybe it doesn't because this was
only tested on a luux machine but that
information wasn't presented anywhere so
that's where uh this is like a concrete
example of where the producibility um
measures were taken to the maybe this is
okay the point is not to you don't have
to do these things the only uh thing I
want to like get across here is like
being aware of where you're Drawing the
Line okay next is how do we improve this
now um we can take six levels of um
trust but it's also six levels of
paranoia right so first things first um
we can have explicit source of packages
and python
interpreters so uh a lot of like at
least um at one side a lot of folks love
cond so we end up using cond
environment. yaml in this uh example
that we just saw of txt was specified
mainly they were expecting folks to use
pip and PPI but being a little more
explicit about that is always
good um you can also
include uh the operating systems that
this application supports if you want to
itally so being explicit is just step
one you're really putting in a lot of
trust in your
delegated uh
box uh next step is you can provide a
lock file so this will include all the
dependencies that we saw in the um the
previous slides right so this loog file
will have all the dependencies and the
exact versions of your packages and the
versions of the dependent uh packages
you can use in the cond world we have
cond lock it's an excellent tool but you
can also do a the if you're if you
prefer after that maybe that's not
enough right you trust
your the the delicated Box even less
like or you're even more paranoid you
can include uh D ball with all the cond
packages that's not enough you can
include a darker image that's not enough
you can provide a VM with cond that's
also not enough you can just ship an
entire PC with everything you want of
course that's like a very very extreme
case right so this is just showing you
the levels of reproducibility like at
six you're actually fully ensuring
reproducibility but uh as I said again
like it's we don't have to do all of
these just having a making conscious
decision about where you draw the line
that's what we going to get across uh a
small note here is when you ship and
vendor packages by licensing is
important to look at like you you may
not need to include certain licensing
files like maybe you don't have the
correct maybe you the license doesn't
allow you to do that so that's something
to consider when you look at the last
few
options now uh now that we've looked at
runtime producibility generally um data
science and F data ecosystem in general
we have an extra set of needs beyond
what we just
saw we have multiple languages and
several packaging ecosystems like very
few packages uh rather even the the
based foundational packages like they
are not pure python packages right so we
need to that adds some complexity in
this system next is especially with the
recent uh AI uh hype I guess uh but also
like just there's a lot of lot of folks
doing dat science and libraries are
moving very very fast which means it's
not always backwards compatible right
and that is problematic because
my uh my application may not work three
months from now um because the library
has moved ahead things are not
compatible anymore next is uh
practitioners do the same with their
environments this means like Breaking
All the Things by this this is the same
as I think the last point which is work
close that don't make reproducibility
easier this is
kind of uh the same in a way because uh
our current workflows uh especially with
K I'm a primarily K user um our
workflows don't enable reproducibility
like it's a lot easier to do K install
lpai in my new environment that's not
the best practice though right because
I'm not adding it to my environment of
yel spec I'm not building a lock file at
the end maybe uh so when we have these
workflows and as a practitioner like I
will end up breaking my environment or
at least uh rather best case not it
won't be reproducible uh if it if if
things don't break so we have extra
problems how do we solve
them um honestly being aware of them uh
is useful like as you just did in this
like uh you've learned from this slide
but like and then you can now um build
for that at quanite where I work we
ended up creating a tool to sort of
bridge this gap for us um so we'll I'll
just show you how we thought of this and
did this but maybe this is too much for
you maybe this is not enough for you so
that's a decision that you will make for
yourself uh so just to give a overview
of what we are trying to do um we want
things to stay reproducible we want data
science environments which we saw comes
with additional complexities to to stay
reproducible but also be flexible and
easy to use because uh if the workflow
for reproducibility is harder folks will
inevitably just fall back to older
patterns which may not ensure
reproducibility right okay so a few
things that we did in cond store to help
with this is we built in a UI uh I
actually have a local demo running so uh
we this is contestor I'm running this
locally if you want to do it I'll share
some I'll share the code uh at the
end uh so this is just a uh UI View
but also uh standard yor if folks prefer
that and uh you can hit create so this
kind of lowered
the this added a little more um added
made the workflow section of following
things easier having a UI an intuitive
is UI right like we know exactly what to
do like I add packages here because
there's a button that says add packages
here I don't have to go through the CLI
and think about like three
commands next
is oh uh we have Version
Control uh this is an environment I just
built for p dat globals I'm just going
to go back to an environment I built
earlier and here I have this one I built
today but there's also a version of this
from November so if I end up breaking
this environment inevitably like if if
if my bill today broke environment I can
just fall back on the previous version I
built uh and that was successfully
built next
is uh ening practices for groups so this
is not super uh obvious from my local
setup but ined version uh we can require
certain oh oh my God I'm so sorry yeah
we can require the use of like internal
mirrors uh we can restrict certain
channels so we can say only use cond or
only use this this particular Channel
this is uh underlying U con is built on
the cond ecosystem so that's that's
where the channels uh vocabulary comes
comes from third is insert required
packages into all environments so I've
highlighted IPI kernel here um we need
that for certain other things in the
system so we just make sure every
environment built will just have IPI
kernel installed by default and lastly
require certain versions of packages
maybe uh you haven't tested the latest
version of bandas so you want to make
sure every every environment built in
your team just uses a version below that
right like or certain version you can do
all of that so enforcing best practices
from a user's perspective I still have
my interface and I can say give me
pandas and like uh I have my drop down
and it only give me certain versions and
I just pick one of them making the
worklow easier but also enforcing
certain
things and this I will show you in con
store uh by default a bunch of artifacts
are created this includes a yaml but
this is a pinned yaml this includes all
uh all the dependencies and exact
versions but also a lock file which is
the exact hash of this but also the lck
file also also
includes the platform details so extra
Hardware information and uh log file and
an archive in the hosted version we also
have
a Docker it should be there somewhere um
yeah we also create Docker image and
Dall so these are again created behind
the scenes I don't have to worry about
it uh I these are required for
reproducibility but I don't have to
create these
manually so with that uh to try condore
for yourself this is I'm hosting this
locally and the local setup for condore
is for only for your doctors this isn't
in the released version yet but to do so
you can look at the slide maybe take a
screenshot or pause if this is a video
and follow along okay so that was that
um but that's where these are the few
things that con started and like that
was enough for our team but maybe you
need to go further right you want to
specify the hardware colel versions
maybe you want to uh you know have a
full VM and yeah there
is you can add more and like design
system for yourself that works and
finally just a note again is the
workflows should enable reproducibility
like you can have the most reproducible
system but unless folks follow it it's
not really useful and finally um with
that we've come to the end of the talk
so I'll leave you with some keyways uh
first things first we discussed like
looking at and making
reproducibility
uh being proactive about it so analyzing
Supply chains and numerating components
thinking about risk uh capturing runtime
details that you don't control which
includes which is a part of the uh
framework right and here just shouting
out a tool called Watermark so this this
is an i python magic that lets you sorry
that that prints a few
um Hardware information like some
Hardware information like in your
jupyter notebook and you can include
this right when you do Version Control
or share your notebook with other folks
um so other untime details you want to
capture are any Randomness date and time
of course Version Control is useful as
we saw with cont store and uh after that
there isum accepted level of risk you're
going to have to uh make a decision
about risk just make sure it's an
educated compromise that you make and
finally test your work um I don't think
we covered this specifically but is
definitely important if your
reproducibility workflow is bad it's
kind of worse than not having
reproducibility in some sense so yeah
with that uh we can uh open for
questions thank you so much
for
do we have the moderator here for the
Q&A or I'll open the chat just a
second have any questions you can drop
them in the
chat is this tied to the cond ecosystem
or does it work without cond um
cond store is built on top of the cond
ecosystem uh it's actually a part of the
cond incubator organization so it uses K
internally right uh but K itself is kind
of um it's a it's not but specific right
you can you can install no Js from cond
so K does allow does have some
flexibility but cond store is currently
built on top of
cond
any other
questions does it work with
M
um it obviously can um like Mamba is
also part of the broader cond ecosystem
so once you have the environment. Yama
that's like created for you like like
the pinam or Lo file you can use you can
do a Mamba install uh so you use M
locally if you want but like underneath
like by default uh cond store like how
the first initial packages like a first
environment is built for you is using
Sol
any other
questions we do have time so if there's
also something you want to go back on uh
I can show off con restore some more if
needed actually I didn't get around to
doing this but uh this blog post by
Anaconda talks about eight levels of
reproducibility uh it's a really nice
block post to check out if uh you're
interested inability this we did refer
to this while preparing the as
well okay looks like we don't have any
more questions so thank you all for
joining uh I will I guess I'll try to
close this session